from when I started on YouTube in 2020
I in June like May June 2020 I had no
subscribers so I got to a million in a
year I had a lot of people analyzing my
every move all of my small flaws and I I
love getting hate comments
because you pin you pin is it the
comment of Shame that's what it was it's
been named over the years by by folks I
never called it that but yeah it's it's
pin of Shame and it's a shame yes it's
been tough because now people pretend to
write hate comments just to get
attention so like anything the public
ruined the good thing
but it started that way it started with
people just shredding me to bits calling
me spin-offs of this and that and um
I think I'm I'm a human more than I am a
Creator an influencer an attention
seeker like I'm just a person so to me
even at the size of 1.6 million
subscribers now September 2022 I don't
understand that I've gotten big and that
I shouldn't do this stuff and that I
should be Beyond it or I shouldn't be
checking my social media as much as I do
and interacting one-on-one I'm still
very much a human being and my guilty
pleasure my way of killing time if I'm
not laying on the couch and playing some
jazz Blitz Games off stream is I just
interact with people who say nice things
and who say horrible things and I really
like to get into the head of the people
who say the terrible things now
sometimes you can sometimes they are
truly Trolls but sometimes people just
they just
just really hate you what's the
successful what's a successful
interaction with the person that's uh
trolling you what's up like at the end
of that Hero Journey that you were uh
yeah uh partaking in what's what's
like what's the top of the mountain look
like is the troll conquered and broken
mentally not no not mental I don't wanna
I don't want to defeat I I honestly
sometimes somebody writes a very long
comment I'll just I'll respond with a
question mark
yeah oh so you're you're you see each
other like like a brother and sister
you're gonna travel together on this
journey of deep meaning like
introspection what does this mean yeah
I've had people write
I can't quote now but something about my
Persona my behavior this and that and I
just like respond to them and I say hey
it sounds crazy that a large Creator
might do something like this but this
kind of goes back to you you speak to
folks on a very respectful way if you
make a mistake you completely own up to
it so I have this sometimes these
one-on-one interactions where I say I
think you're reading too much into this
I think you're kind of you don't
understand maybe some of my humor or
sarcasm as such so you form this opinion
that I'm this kind of a person this and
that and now you're sort of anything I
do you're trying to attach to that
reasoning and here you are writing this
lengthy essay of why nobody should watch
my content and sometimes people go you
know what I think you have a point maybe
I should relax a little bit yeah I would
love I would love to sort of interview
and understand
the lives of the the folks that post
that kind of stuff I mean they're
they're human beings they have
interesting Journeys also I think they
often don't realize
I think they don't realize their comment
will be read by anybody especially you
maybe they think like they also don't
realize you're a human being